thank you whatever
I'm just watching she'll carry this is
nice isn't it yeah I'm actually really
enjoying it to be fair yeah I know but
I'm like I know it's a lie but I just I
just can't stop watching mine it's just
goody sake hi trash really yeah yeah I
know look I mean say Clark trash as well
so I know exactly what you mean yeah I
don't really see what's so great about
ref Thalia but did you hit the captain
pensions do the music for it it's pretty
high yeah Oh Kevin thank you he's the
guy who put the music from no no no no
no before that
Oh Roth Talent yeah I don't see what's
so great about her I think feelings way
that it's just kind of refreshing to see
a main character that doesn't have to
kill everything
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah I'm I'm sorry what you think
some five day old chocobo over the
loving embrace of the purest raccoon
girl this year what are you some sick
Tyler you're like 12 raccoon yeah she'd
be a grown woman right myself to you
she's a ball of sunshine and love and
you don't deserve her anyway gone what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
I'm an extreme distress and how [ __ ]
your opinion is I mean honestly I really
just don't understand the appeal of her
she's kind of like every other good bit
of white gum what are you doing I'm
trying to find a glove to slap you in
the face with that chill oh it's just
anime wife who's man
it's Warner are we really making a big
deal out of this
you're like a brother to me I thought we
had this unshakeable bond that couldn't
be broken by anything
who else corner who else have you
backstabbing with using your awful taste
it's not it's kind of funny actually I
was spinning to tell you that Rica's
thighs on that thing like are you
disrespecting me in my own house when
you know this is my house okay for the
last time it was the bareness of her
thighs combined with her thigh to waist
ratio that caused everyone to call it
thick do you know no I mean it just
boils down to who has the better hentai
of them hand side how long until you
searched an entire house is this what
you think this is about I genuinely love
her design she just seems like a chill
person I would actually hang out with in
real life best girl is so much more than
just hentai so how long until you sir
Japan almost immediately yeah that's
what I thought who else who was best
girl in funny girl senpai kinda wrong
it was my darling in the Franks Ichigo
do you just want to see the world burn
we know what was wrong with her what she
calls the big enough shitstorm the
United Nations treated it as an
international incident I just thought
she was the best girl on the show oh my
god I thought being objectively wrong
was just an urban legend I just think
that 0-2 was a bit overrated and
everyone was obsessed with him gone what
are you doing hi there can you connect
me to the police I'd like to report hey
don't you can't call 999 for that that's
not a crime oh yeah why don't you tell
them about all the lollies you've
watched in Adam
you and I both knows that as long as
she's a 200-yard lolly
there is absolutely no moral obligation
to feel weird about anything at all yeah
yeah you're right that's just the law
right yeah I mean you know also she's a
demon lord that holds up in a court of
law
thank you something we finally agree on
like this is this is stupid we're
sitting here arguing about the fictional
aspects of girls that don't exist I mean
come on my friends how long we known
each other we can respect each other's
tastes yeah sorry I just
[Music]